[Music]
on this Sunday night the manhunt for
Quebec father his two daughters are dead
could he be hiding in the thick dense
forest and for how long
revisiting the deadly missile strike
that killed dozens of Canadians you
cannot today as your own another country
for justice who's being blamed for
Iran's military mistake watched the
struggle to make face masks mandatory
what a police were not by law the safety
measures getting pushed back and the
pandemic strikes Bollywood a family
dynasty exposed to Cova 19
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us an intense manhunt is still underway
in Quebec tonight police have not found
the father of two young girls found dead
in a community south of Quebec City the
bodies of six yield Romi an 11 year old
norica Ponte were found yesterday in a
heavily wooded area the sisters were the
subject of an Amber Alert earlier this
week but police have not located their
dad
investigators believe he's still in the
area globals Olivia O'Malley has
tonight's top story
Quebec provincial police have spent all
day Sunday combing the dense woods in
Santa Pollyanna about 30 minutes
southwest of quebec city by foot atv and
helicopter sparing no expense in the
manhunt for 44 year-old Martin
Carpentier's police have confirmed he is
a suspect in the criminal investigation
into the deaths of his two daughters
six-year-old Romi and 11 year old Nora
for sure is a suspect in the event that
we have actually but for the cause of
the death we're gonna wait for the
autopsy to be done on the two young
girls while officers have not come in
contact with cop on ta they believe he
is not far from where the girls bodies
were found Saturday people who live in
the area reported seeing car on CA but
so far that's the only sighting if we do
arrest him it will be a major
information that he can tell us about
all the sick ones that happened in that
event the girls and their father were
members of a Quebec Scouts group the
organization has created a memorial for
Romeo and Nora in Livi the town where
the family is from members of the scouts
group didn't want to speak on camera but
they say they wanted the memorial to be
there for the girl's family they say it
started small but throughout Sunday
members of the community came by to pay
their respects police are asking Saint
apollyon out residents to stay vigilant
but to also leave the investigation to
officers on Saturday night they ran into
trouble with people searching in the
woods within the police perimeter since
we're doing a criminal investigation
important elements can be still on the
side or around in the area police are
asking residents to stay on their
property and if they see carp on c8 not
to engage and call 9-1-1 Olivia O'Malley
Global News Santa Polly in there a
report of Iran is shutting some new
light on the downing of a Ukrainian
airliner in January
all 176 people on board were killed
including 55 Canadians the Iranian
government eventually admitted
responsibility but the flights data
recorder still hasn't been turned over
to international authorities and as
Heather expressed explains this new
report is providing little comfort to
those who lost loved ones
Edmonton xemnas nabe II was one of 176
people killed in the downing of flight
752 for her grieving husband months may
have passed but the pain is still
incredibly fresh I didn't even touch her
clothes or shoes like so many others who
lost loved ones in the January crash
Javad Soleimani is looking for justice
and accountability Iran initially denied
responsibility only changing course days
later admitting it was responsible for
shooting down the passenger jet but
since then the international
investigation has been painfully slow
now a report from iran's Civil Aviation
Organization has found errors made by
the crew manning a missile battery were
largely to blame the report outlined
several key moments that led to the
crash the surface-to-air missile battery
had been moved and was misaligned as
well those Manning the missile battery
could not communicate with their command
center and opened fire twice without
getting approval from ranking officials
the report also noted that the Ukrainian
flight had done nothing out of the
ordinary when the missiles were launched
I think the big challenge is going to be
you know why did why did the Iranians
knowing that they were going to have
such activity in the skies allow
civilian aircraft to be in there in the
first place it's not enough to just say
there's a breakdown in communication
there should have been a stoppage of all
civilian aircraft frankly in the air
six people believed to be involved in
the incident have been arrested and
after a lengthy delay
says it plans to send the black box to
France later this month to be examined
the Canadian government is among those
waiting for that information
a spokesperson for Global Affairs Canada
said in a statement to Global News
immediate action is required from the
Iranian regime to ensure they conduct a
comprehensive and transparent
investigation in accordance with
international standards
it's what family members are anxiously
waiting for as well we are just silent
cannot another country for justice
Heather Eric's West Global News Calgary
turning now to the pandemic anyone
living in Montreal who attended a bar or
Club this month is being urged to get
tested for covin 19 at least five bars
in the city have reported cases since
July first eight people have tested
positive for the virus but health
officials believe there are likely more
they're now trying to track down all
customers and employees but it's
difficult to do if establishments are
not keeping proper records we have a
growing number of cases in a bunch of
different places brought us to the
conclusion that in order to get in front
of it we wanted to send out a call to
the whole population rather than go bar
by bar or situation by situation anyone
showing kovat 19 symptoms should isolate
while waiting for test results Quebec
still has the most confirmed cases in
the country it added a hundred and
fourteen new cases today bringing its
total to more than 56,000 doctors say
one way to reduce the spread of the new
corona virus is to wear face masks and
more municipalities are making it
mandatory but not all places are
enforcing the rule the same way and as
Karen Lieberman reports not everyone
wants to cover up either
as provinces and territories east Ovid
19 restrictions more people are
venturing out to restaurants cafes and
shopping malls and a growing number of
cities are mandating they wear masks in
public you know you look at cities
across the world that have put in a
policy like this it's made a dramatic
difference Brampton is one of the latest
cities in Ontario to implement a
mandatory mask by law but there is no
province wide rule leaving the decision
to individual regions look what's
happening in the states with everybody
not wearing a mask and Florida and Texas
and that and look at their numbers
versus our numbers in Montreal a mask by
law comes into effect at the end of the
month the town of Murcia Quebec is not
waiting after a kovat 19 outbreak linked
to house parties I want to make sure
nobody's gonna get it from me
because I can have it and I and I don't
know I have it right the question in
cities that are making masks mandatory
is how it'll be enforced under the order
businesses can refuse entry to anyone
not wearing a face covering that puts
the onus on the owner and the client
could face a fine or in most cases just
a simple warning everyone's wearing
masks and even though no one's out
ticketing everyone is it's top of mind
for everyone we're not police we're not
by law we're just trying to work with
walking out live for us not everyone is
reacting kindly to the suggestion I'm
not the video but making me service this
Toronto woman who refused to wear a mask
in a hospital faced backlash after
posting online about it while the
current science suggests masks helped
contain the spread of the virus experts
so far are not pushing for a national
mandate given that we have only about
200 to 400 new cases of Copan 19 per day
I think it would be very challenging to
have a nationwide mandate this
infectious diseases specialist points to
Alberta which has found ways to nudge
people to work masks wearing they're
giving them out at drive-through
restaurants they're giving them out at
places that are high-risk so for example
congregate settings like long term care
settings homeless shelters you give
everyone the opportunity for death
Karen Lieberman Global News Toronto
in the US the virus is showing no signs
of slowing down
Florida has shattered a single day
record reporting more than 15,000 new
confirmed cases that's the largest
one-day increase of any state since the
pandemic began as Jennifer Johnson
explains the startling new numbers come
as the American government debates how
to reopen schools new cases of Coppa 19
continue to break state-to-state daily
records Florida North Carolina and Texas
all reporting staggering increases
states across the country are being
forced to close businesses again as the
pandemic continues to spread
despite that the Trump administration
wants schools to reopen in just a few
weeks there is no nothing in the data
that would suggest that kids being back
in school is is dangerous to them and in
fact it's it's more a matter of their
health and well-being that they be back
in school but massive covin 19 outbreaks
have occurred in Texas daycare centers
and summer camps and other states while
millions of parents want their children
to go back to school millions of others
and many teachers are concerned young
children won't keep their masks on I
just can't imagine having my six and
seven year olds wearing a mask correctly
school districts across the u.s. are
debating plans on how to safely reopen
many proposing a hybrid option a
half-day Learning remotely a half day in
school officials and hotspots are
scrambling we're going to obviously do
our very best in our community
considering where the health data
currently is at positivity rate of 29.1%
a month ago it was a 6% a commentary in
the medical journal Pediatrics concluded
children do not frequently transmit the
virus and schools can and should reopen
in the fall with masks and proper
physical distancing but federal health
officials say adults need to do their
part to we can turn this thing around in
two to three weeks if we can get a
critical mass of people wearing faith
covering US President Donald Trump wore
a mask for the first time in public when
he visited Walter Reed military Medical
Center Saturday he has faced months of
backlash for not wearing a mask while as
administrations doctors urge all
Americans to use one
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
the new coronavirus has hit Bollywood
royalty tonight with three generations
of the button family now infected the
king of Indian cinema Amitabh Bachchan
and his actor son Abhishek are both
being treated in hospital with
apparently mild symptoms Abbas ex-wife
Bollywood star and former Miss World
Aishwarya Rai and the couple's
eight-year-old daughter also have the
virus
mom and daughter don't have any symptoms
so they will quarantine at home the
daily Koba 19 caseload has shattered a
record in India in the past 24 hours
more than 28,000 people there have
tested positive for Cova 19 India has
the third highest number of cases in the
world behind the u.s. and Brazil Global
News has learned the Wii charity has
laid up contract workers hired to
deliver the federal government's student
grant service in a statement the
organization says with the government
funding no longer available we had to
make the incredibly difficult decision
to end the contracts meantime the
federal Conservative Party is calling on
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau to testify
before a parliamentary committee it will
examine his government's decision to
award we charity with the now scrapped
900 million dollar contract despite his
family's ties to the organisation
normally Prime Minister's don't appear
before parliamentary committees but
these are not normal times this scandal
is about him and him alone it is his
family the Trudeau family that got the
money it is him that made the decision
to give this organization a billion
dollar sole sourced competition-free
contract the Conservatives will need
support from the bloc québécois and the
NDP to compel Trudeau to appear Finance
Minister Bill Morneau who also has
family ties to the charity is also being
called on to testify an explosion off
the coast of San Diego
coming up the fire that erupted on this
Navy ship plus the heat wave hitting the
US
firefighters are battling this huge
blaze on a navy ship docked in San Diego
Bay
the fire spread across the USS BONHOMME
RICHARD this morning after reports of an
explosion the ship was undergoing
routine maintenance at the time 160
sailors were on board when the fire
started 18 of them were taken to
hospital with non-life threatening
injuries heat alerts are in place across
much of the US tonight
in Texas several cities including Dallas
are expected to see the temperature rise
to at least 37 degrees Celsius despite
the heat dozens of texts and spent the
day outside waiting in line for summer
food staples in California people
flocked to beaches in an attempt to beat
the heat more than 20 locations across
the US could break temperature records
over the next few days in Hong Kong
people lined up for hours in the heat to
vote in an unofficial primary election
the city's pro-democracy group is
holding the vote before it selects
candidates for an upcoming election
hundreds of thousands of Hong Kongers
have cast a ballot despite warnings that
doing so could violate the new national
security law Beijing imposed the
controversial law on Hong Kong last
month it criminalizes virtually all
forms of dissent still ahead living with
the coronavirus what happened with Cova
19 is here to stay
watching global national some public
health and infectious disease experts
are pressing for provincial and federal
governments to shift in minimising not
eradicating kovat 19 to basically accept
this disease will be with us for a long
time joining us to talk about that is
dr. Vivek Gowell former president of
public health Ontario dr. GU Lu have
said that aiming to prevent or contain
every case of covin 19 is simply no
longer sustainable why not well once we
got to the stage that we did back in
March with widespread community
transmission the WHL when it declared
the pandemic they said it's time to move
from containment which is a strategy of
eliminating disease to mitigation that
is reducing the impact and the effects
of the disease but we allow society to
get on as much as possible and the other
reason why containment is no longer an
effective strategy for us is what's
happening everywhere else in the world
so if you think of small island
countries like Iceland New Zealand have
pursued a containment strategy have
strict border controls we're not in the
same sort of situation we're next to a
country that is not containing the
disease we rely on that country for
critical supply chains and even with the
border controls that we have we will
continue to have imported cases so to go
after a strategy where we try to
eliminate every case would mean not only
keeping our economy shut down but
putting a virtual seal around our
borders like some of those other
countries have done which is not
sustainable for Canada would it be
foolish to jeopardize the progress
Canada has made up to this point by
opening the border I certainly would not
be recommending lifting them at the
present time with what's going on right
now but we need to start thinking about
what we're going to do in the future as
the United States and then the states
that are hardest hit right now start to
bring things under control and we need
to think about
risk-based approach to opening up our
border so rather than saying Canadians
should avoid non-essential travel to all
countries of the world which is the
current recommendation start to look
like at what countries or regions like
the EU have done where they have
identified countries that don't have
community transmission and are lifting
the quarantine requirement and in fact
they've lifted the quarantine
requirement for Canada because they see
Canada's having managed the outbreak but
Canada has not lifted the quarantine
requirement for residents of the EU
you've indicated the current approach to
dealing with kovat 19 carries
significant risk to overall population
health what do you mean by that the
restrictions have also had an impact on
the healthcare system itself we have
people who have had their procedures
cancelled we have people that have had
medical visits canceled and as a result
of that they're going to be suffering
consequences we have a decrease in
emergency department visits have been
reporting United States for a heart
attack for stroke for diabetes
complications those people are going to
have consequences we have all of the
impact on children the early childhood
development is one of the strongest
predictors of lifelong health we have
increases in domestic violence we have
food and security we have increases in
drug and alcohol use all of these things
over the longer term will have an impact
on health and then the unemployment
itself leads to increased health
consequences so I think the critical
thing to remember is that the public
health measures themselves have
consequences dr. Koh well thank you for
your time
up next no Olympics no problem
how to run a global race in the pan
demmick
in an ideal time the Tokyo Olympic Games
would have kicked off in less than two
weeks of course they've now been
postponed because of the pandemic but
last week track-and-field fans hungry
for international competition still got
their wishes granted well sort of our
Mike Armstrong explains how one unique
event in Switzerland pulled off a
worldwide race hello and welcome to the
Vell classes Eric inspiration games in a
normal year this event would have 25,000
people packed into the stands with Kovac
19 that wasn't possible but organizers
really didn't want to cancel its new
it's different it's a challenge bear
with us
now here's what made it complicated the
event was spread out in seven arenas
around the world in the women's 100
meters competitors stepped up to the
blocks in California Florida and
Switzerland that you can see that slight
headwind in Zurich the runners actually
raced with no one beside them making it
a little rough on the announcer hard to
tell who's gonna get to the line first
the racers ran simultaneously then
editors stitched the whole thing
together in a matter of minutes so it
seemed like one race it's gonna be very
tight and deep no the results were
probably less important than the fact
the competition took place at all with
amateur events around the world canceled
this summer some might have trouble ever
coming back and okay
pole vault this event might have been a
little gimmicky but at least it gave
Zurich organizers some you go missing a
year think of the damage that could be
done to what minimal branding they
already have it is when the event wasn't
really a model going forward you can't
have some competitors and sunny climates
against others dealing with wind and
rain but there weren't many competitors
complaining canada's Andre de Grasse won
his event he says it was just nice to be
in a facility that was actually open
yeah I mean it's been really tough I
mean you know the past couple months you
know we only been training like two to
three days a week oh well we've been
trying to bounce from you know track the
track getting kicked off here and there
no
Lyle's in California sorry in Florida
excuse me
there was one snafu in the men's 200
meters it appeared a runner had beaten
Usain Bolt's world record that cannot be
right it turned out that crews in
Florida had set up the blocks at the
wrong spot the runner had only done 185
meters Mike Armstrong Global News
Montreal and that is global national for
this July 12 I'm Robin Gill tonight your
Canada is angle Mont BC we'd love to see
your corner of this country so email
your photos to viewers at global
national comm thank you for watching and
I'll see you back here tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]